i'm talking about the constitution uh
that 233 year old rule book for american
life and governance that is especially
relevant
right at this moment consider this the
inauguration process detailed in the
20th amendment
the impeachment process that is
described in article 1 sections 2 and 3
and the 2020 election results were
certified by the states and counted by
congress
all of it in accordance with article 2
and the 12th amendment
here's the problem for all of its wisdom
the constitution
is in trouble for this reason most
americans
do not know what's in it
we the people have been talking a lot
about our founding document
this document republicans and democrats
say
they're protecting it we love the
constitution
we love america
and president trump referenced the
constitution no fewer than 16
times ahead of the riot at the capitol
this month urging supporters to fight a
supposedly unconstitutional election
you're sworn to uphold our constitution
we are living in unprecedented times
jeffrey rosen is a cbs news
constitutional law expert the person we
turn to for knowledge of our nation's
charter
the constitution is a 7 500 word
blueprint for america
establishing our national government
basic rights and a process for
addressing our problems
at least in theory the constitution
provides as many questions
and answers and it provides a
forum or a platform for civil dialogue
and debate
so we can peacefully resolve those
questions
rosen is also president of the national
constitution
center where web traffic is at an
all-time high
which isn't exactly a good thing what
does it say about us as a country
that at this moment in time so many of
us had to go to the national
constitution center to refresh our
memory
of the document that undergirds our
country
there's no doubt that we are in a crisis
of civic education the framers knew that
the consequences of constitutional
ignorance
and being guided by passion rather than
reason were on mobs
well we just saw that they were right
about that
[Music]
every immigrant to this country has to
pass a civics test to become
a naturalized citizen so we borrowed
some basic questions from that very exam
we've got some trivia questions can we
ask you a few to get a sense of just how
deep a crisis we're in how many people
are in the house of representatives i
don't know
12. 14 the house
for the whole country 80. we assumed
americans by birth
might do at least as well as americans
by choice
but can you name the three branches of
government
judicial yeah that's one oh
my husband's gonna kill me
however the vast majority of people were
stumped
who is the chief justice of the united
states supreme court
do we have nine of them we have nine of
them and there's a chief
i don't know the chief justice trump the
chief justice is not trump
sometimes their fellow americans tried
to help chief justice of the supreme
court
john roberts yes there it is he got it
well done
but it was clear most people could use a
refresher
who signs a bill into law it's not
officially a law until this person signs
it
as uh what do you call his name again
boy oh you know this
and many of us haven't read the
constitution in years
if ever oh it's been a minute it's been
a minute yeah oh
god probably middle school ever
never never read it i'm sure hardly
anybody read it
and sure enough a 2019 survey found only
four out of every 10 americans could
pass the citizenship test
that feels like an embarrassment to me
you could call it a scandal i call it
actually a proxy for a larger set
of problems raj venakota runs the
non-profit that conducted that survey
the institute for citizens and scholars
aims to re-imagine
and rebuild the field of civic learning
in order to reconnect america
to its constitutional roots so you need
to understand how our government works
and elections and so on
but you also need to understand why we
set it up that way
and if you don't understand both of
those pieces you are going to be in
trouble
and you can actually function
effectively in our society what worries
me the most about constitutional
ignorance is the same
worry that the framers had that without
constitutional education
the republic will collapse and he's not
kidding about that i mean
we were supposed to know this thing the
good news is it is a very slim volume it
is not a big book
this is how thin the constitution is you
can also get a little tiny one that you
can carry around
you put it in your pocket uh you know so
but there's a serious point
behind this which is you know we did a
poll just yesterday that found that a
majority of republicans don't think joe
biden was legitimately elected and as a
legitimate
president well the constitution says
otherwise a process was followed
yeah and if you disagree with that
process there's a constitutional process
for changing it four years from now yeah
we can't function as a democracy unless
we follow the rules in this little book
i was shocked that president
trump mentioned the constitution 16
times in that speech i have to say yeah
shouldn't you give the people the
correct answers i know people are
watching at home
because we were all playing you're going
to put me on the spot so that i should
no no i'm not no i'm not no i'm not i
just figure you must have some kind of
sheet where the answers are
well so i know legislative executive
judicial every question that we if
people want to test themselves and i
took the test myself every question
is uh on the civics exam that uh
citizens to the u.s naturalized citizens
take
there's a hundred questions i would have
liked to see you address those same
questions to to to em recent immigrants
who
are they where did you get it i actually
did find one uh but she taken the test
30 years ago and forgotten everything
yeah
the only person who got all the
questions that we asked was a cbs this
morning viewer who declined to be named
but we appreciate you sir
very much yeah and there was another
young woman named amber abdul
also very impressive got all but one the
only one she missed is who is her
representative in congress that was an
easy one it was a gimmick
i'm amazed at how many people can't
answer that question i know i love the
uh john roberts question
to the guy who answered it is he as he
didn't even break his stride
and said john roberts what's going on
yeah he does i thought that was alright
read the constitution this weekend
people a little homework for you all